do you want to know what it is huge news
coming out yesterday I was a big matrix
fan growing up so I couldn't not talk
about it Keanu Reeves and carrie-anne
moss will be back reprising their roles
as Neil and Trinity with lana wachowski
set to direct which is a bit odd since
neo sacrificed himself at the end of
Matrix Revolutions but if you recall the
ending of that movie the character sati
asked this of the Oracle she's of course
referring to neo but more ominous is the
scene just before this where the Oracle
talks to the architect in which he asked
her how long this piece between humans
and machines will last hinting that the
enslavement of people within the matrix
is a never-ending cycle the main theory
going around right now and this is the
one that's the most straightforward is
that the consciousness of both neo and
Trinity have somehow been uploaded to
the matrix they aren't quite programs
nor human allowing them to maintain
peace between humans and the machines
the matrix also played heavily into many
Buddhist philosophies such as there is
no reality you create your own reality
and control your mind control your life
Buddhists also believe in reincarnation
so if the writers continue their foray
into Buddhist theology that may play
heavily into how neo and Trinity make it
back joining lana wachowski as co-writer
czar alexander hemin and david mitchell
who wrote the novel Cloud Atlas which
the Wachowskis also adapted Lily
wachowski who isn't involved with the
project at this time has given her
blessing stating that she expects it to
be better than the original the project
itself was greenlit after Warner
Brothers was so impressed with the story
and also the resurgence of Keanu Reeves
as a box-office star production is
scheduled to begin in early 2020 and
knowing how VFX intensive Matrix movies
are it'll probably be 2021 before it's
even released reports in 2017 stated
that a different Matrix movie was in the
works with Michael B Jordan to star and
a script written by ready player one
Zack Penn
however with the latest announcement
it's safe to say that that's been
cancelled there's also no word yet if
Laurence Fishburne or Hugo Weaving will
be back to reprise their roles as
Morpheus and Agent Smith respectively
but anything is possible in the matrix
so don't count them out even if it means
us seeing a younger version of Morpheus
which Variety reported may be recast for
a younger take the studio had previously
been considering a matrix prequel
revolving around a young Morpheus that's
all we know so far for matrix for stay
tuned to the channel for more updates
breakdowns and theories as this will
surely be a movie to keep our eyes on
you can follow me on youtube at things
story whitey and until next time
remember daddy loves you very much